from Palestine to Europe just letting
you I'm I'm looking left and right
because I'm being told that the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
going to be speaking at some point so
when that happens we'll carry that life
however I want to um right we're seeing
the the picture of that now you see the
Israeli Flags you see the podium here he
is Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu
[Music]
for yes sir
okay you're listening to the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu uh
quite clearly he is speaking Hebrew
right now we are getting a translation
for you in a very short order as soon as
we get that in English uh
we okay I believe you're about to get
the
translation we will
continue intensifying the operations
against Hamas six
point is to reinforce all the other
fronts the borders with Lebanon West
Bank I would like to support and voice
my support to all the forces and the
Army and all those who are
working and there are sacrificing their
their lives in order to protect
Israel the fourth point is to
continue to have international support I
started mobilizing the International
Community so that we can have a margin
where we can work and continue our
operations and the next point that is
very important
also is to unify the people there is no
split within Israelis now we are all
unified the leadership also should be
unified I'm calling for Unity and I'm
calling the
opposition to have a
national
front as we did during The Six Day
War I confirm that we have started
attacking Hamas the photos that and
pictures that you see from Hamas is just
the beginning we have killed many of
those Fighters and I said that
everyone every place where Hamas is
active and working will be completely
destroyed and we will continue to
intensify the operations I am
in I'm always talking I'm still talking
with President Biden and I would like to
thank the United States for their
support and for supporting
Israel we have the biggest planes that
are coming from the United States to our
land I would like also to thank many
International leaders who have show and
expressed their support for
Israel there is a lot of
defamation that wants to exercise and
exert a pressure on
us and there is a lot of misin
misinformation about the operations and
a situation in Israel we should not fall
for those lies and
propaganda we have to also and always
just stick to the official
forces I know that this will take time
but I promise
you dear citizens that this battle will
not end
until until we end and eliminate our
enemy
there are a lot of battles that are
going on and we have a lot of Heroes
that are in the
battlefield and our forces are trying to
eliminate the vandalizers and this is
our spirit we will be together and work
together hand in
hand we have
seen
Soldier
yesterday yesterday I have appointed
General Dan Hills
as as the first focal point for the
captives and we will work and we do
all oh what we can in order
to have those captives back
we also voice our solidarity with all
the
families we have also mobilized all the
police forces and everyone to work on
this
issue this is not this is what is
happening is
reality and this is what links us to
each other together we will win and only
together we will win and as
the Prime Minister I have to tell you
that we have hard days coming we are
very sad for those who died but we are
committed to win and we will win so that
we
can our country can Thrive again and
have a prosperous life for our nation
Israel is a model and all those who
supports Israel
will be we have to
commit to this we have to stick to this
commitment we have to meet our
objectives